digital and social world we are all in
right now has so many positives but like
the polarity two sides of a coin it has
some you know negatives let's face it
and um I swear when it comes to
Parenting I never knew my life
experience of having too much access to
everything would be what all children
are experiencing today so how do we
navigate it all and keep our kids safe
this is our new normal and we have some
help because we're teaming up with bark
Technologies who has been here on the
show before to share some easy and
practical parenting pointers because
this is all new for us and I love bark
so much say hello to Bark's Chief
parenting officer to Tanya Jordan
welcome back
you have an interesting statistic to
share I'm excited to hear this because
I'm always listening for them according
to a Pew research study two-thirds of
parents say that parenting in a tech
role today is way harder than it was 20
years ago and I know you're feeling and
I am as well
it's just the world has changed so much
how do we navigate it what's your first
tip so my first tip is not to give your
child access to devices and gaming
consoles and apps that you have not
navigated first you have to spend time
where they're spending time you know
you're probably all familiar with
Instagram and tick tock tick tock but
yeah do you know what Discord is have
you Googled to see how to navigate be
real have you heard of Omegle no I like
the idea of be real it's great but I
haven't been on it if your kids are
going to be on it you need to be on it
know the landscape where your kid is
hanging out whether it's in real life or
digitally what about Roblox Roblox which
gives me vertigo and makes me want to
vomit but the kids love it I literally
think you'll be like look at this thing
and I'm like oh
Roblox has built-in parental controls
and the great thing about it is that you
can Google them go to whatever your kid
is using whatever the name is then the
words parental and controls and take the
time to investigate how you can keep
your kid safer online wherever they're
playing okay you have thoughts on like
where in the home kids phones and adults
phones should be charged please tell us
about it because I think it could be a
real game changer yeah I really try to
be super non-judgmental but don't charge
your phone in your room at night and
don't let your kids have their phones in
their bedroom at night lead by example
you'll set a great example for mental
health and overall Wellness if you don't
have phones in the bedroom tatanya I'm
on it tonight I'm so proud thank you for
introducing that to me I don't want my
own in my bedroom but I am an absolute
prisoner to the alarm clock thinking
that this is the only way even though I
just bought my kids alarm clocks what's
your final tip so I am so excited to
announce right here on the Drew
Barrymore show that bark has launched
their very own smartphone for kids
really yes
[Applause]
and so my final tip for parents is that
if you're going to give your kid a
smartphone and you know they want one go
with the bark phone it's the safest
first phone for kids it's the safest
phone for kids period to Tanya one thing
I thought was interesting about the new
bark phone is that they've designed it
to look like a smartphone so they'll be
more drawn to this because it looks more
like a smartphone than a kid phone it's
a phone that kids actually want it
doesn't look like a kid phone it looks
like our phones it's so cool but good
for parents it's different for every
person I like that you lack in judgment
because it's not a one size fits-all
thing but this I can really get into and
feel good about you've been waiting for
something like this it's the easiest for
parents to manage remotely and you can
still text and track but you can limit
and monitor does it have that feature
where you can like after a certain
amount of time like cut them off shut it
down shut it down
we all need one of those you can turn it
from a smartphone to a dumb phone if you
need to a smartphone to a dumb phone
well guess what our entire studio
audience is going to go home with one
free year of Bark's Parental Control
software
so
I trust this company implicitly I'm in
it with you guys I'm trying to figure
this all out and I just thank you to
Tanya and bark for like helping me
navigate this thank you for helping us
keep children safe across the globe oh
thank you I care so much about this as a
parent I really want to get it right so
thank you to Tanya we'll be right back
[Music]